tax
the
rich
sometimes a few simple words is all it
takes to set things off we cannot afford
to continue this level of income and
wealth inequality do you want a symbolic
high tax rate on on the high income
people to win votes politically or do
you really want more tax revenue coming
into the government good times are to
their benefit crises are even more to
their benefit they get further and
further and further ahead i'm just
asking you to practice what you preach
let me ask you one other question here i
do practice what i treat well you don't
i'm calling people
the government you're not tension
between wealthy elites and everyone else
is certainly nothing new but in the
2020s with a widening income gap rising
inflation high gas prices astronomical
home values offshore tax havens the
billionaire space race and a shrinking
middle class the question of what
governments should do about the
ultra-rich has become a central one in
economic policy
recently
president joe biden pitched a two-fold
solution for america
the first part is a minimum tax rate of
at least 20 percent on the wealthiest
americans on their full income including
unrealized appreciation of assets or
capital gains
taxing unrealized appreciation is
important to remember since capital
gains are normally taxed after you sell
an asset and collect a profit the second
part is a separate tax at death on most
previously untaxed gains from
appreciated assets even if the assets
are not sold our income tax
is progressive that as you make more
income
you pay higher taxes higher tax rates
however
our income tax
fails to pick up
all of what people might think of as
income
and our income tax system does not tax
appreciation as you go along
although biden's plan has been dubbed
the billionaire tax it actually targets
households with a net worth of 100
million dollars or more so what are some
of the arguments for and against this
idea let's start with the ones in favor
billionaires often pay lower tax rates
than the average american warren buffett
once famously pointed this out comparing
his own rate to his secretary debbie
bosonic
in 2010 buffett's income tax rate was
17.4 percent
while bosonics was 35.8 percent i think
it should be a defining issue debbie
works just as hard as i do and she pays
at twice the rate i pay i think that's
outrageous the biden white house
looked at the forbes 400 wealthiest
households
and they determined that if you counted
unrealized gain as income the effective
tax rate
by these 400 households
was about 8
and the effective tax rate
for a typical worker in the u.s
income tax rate is closer to 22
billionaires can also borrow money
against their accumulated gains on
assets without triggering capital gains
this allows individuals to not declare
income and not be obligated to pay
income taxes
elon musk is a good example of this
a propublica investigation showed
between 2014 and 2018
musk's wealth grew by 13.8 billion
dollars but he paid 455 million dollars
in income taxes during that same period
in 2018 he paid zero federal income
taxes but in december 2021 in a twitter
clapback to senator elizabeth warren
musk claimed he would be paying more
taxes than any american in history that
year
he later tweeted his tab was above 11
billion dollars
the bill was so big because he exercised
millions of stock options which are
taxed at a high ordinary tax rate if the
white house were able to regularly claim
taxes from billionaires they believe the
deficit would be reduced by 360 billion
dollars in the next 10 years
the plan would also tax billionaires
annually as they go just like everyone
else
finally collecting annual taxes on
unrealized gains would reduce the
ability of the ultra-rich to hide money
in tax shelters or to pass down assets
to errors with gains never being taxed
these assets can be passed on to their
ears
with what is known as a step up in basis
and the ears take
the assets
at their full fair market value and this
massive amount
of appreciation
that potentially should be taxed
vanishes now for some of the arguments
against the proposal
first calculating how to tax unsold
assets is very complicated especially
when some assets such as fine art are
hard to value and publicly traded stocks
can go down as well as up if we rely on
a deemed sale and not a true sale well
we have no sales price
as reference
we have to guess what the assets going
to be worth if there were a sale
second when you lack an actual sale
the taxpayer who is deemed to make the
sale
might not have the dollars to pay the
tax
and so that imposes a liquidity
barrier to trying to squeeze out
taxes from someone who hasn't sold any
now the biden billionaire tax
tries to make allowances for both of
these
uh difficulties
the american tax system is already very
complicated and difficult to administer
adding another level of bureaucracy to
calculate these new taxes could make
things even more inefficient biden's tax
would target the biggest job and wealth
creators in america this could then
affect their ability to promote more
economic and technological growth again
elon musk is cited as an example to
support this argument he took the excess
capital from creating a brand new
industry in electric cars and went into
space in a way that the government never
could he beat them at their own game we
need people like that finally the
ability for the federal government to
tax property is constitutionally
questionable as this is typically the
realm of state and local taxes the u.s
constitution
limits the type of taxes our federal
government can impose
and it's unclear whether biden's
billionaire tax
can fall within the safe harbor of our
income tax or whether it would be viewed
as a tax on wealth or property
and that generally cannot be done under
our constitution
as for whether or not this proposed tax
will be enacted the chances are slim
democratic senator joe manchin whose
vote would be needed to pass the
billionaire plan
has already said he will not support
taxing unrealized gains
however even if the plan does not go
ahead the notion that the ultra-rich
have to pay their fair share is a
message we'll likely keep hearing on the
campaign trail heading into the midterm
elections
[Music]
you